YURI GRINSHTEYN: The most
important feature of any system
is its reliability.
This is the driving principle
behind cyber reliability
engineering as invented
and practiced at Google.
This is because you can
easily lose the trust
and respect of your users.
If your service
becomes too unreliable,
or is simply perceived
as being too unreliable,
those countless hours you've
spent designing and building
the most amazing
user experiences
are all for nothing if your
users can't access them.
But it's not enough to just
declare that your services must
be more reliable.
Reliability must be a shared
goal for many different parts
of your organization.
Today, I'm going to
start showing you
how you can consistently
define reliability targets
for your services using SLOs.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first thing
we need to define
is what we mean when
we say "service."
For our purposes, we'll mostly
refer to one of these three.
The first kind of service may
be an application with a user
interface that's
accessed by actual humans
to perform various tasks.
We refer to those
humans as "users,"
and we very much care
about keeping them happy,
so that they continue
to use our service.
We'll measure their
happiness in terms
of things like availability
and performance.
The second kind
of service may be
an API, accessed by
other systems or services
to send or retrieve information.
We may refer to the systems that
use our service as "consumers."
Their happiness
is also important,
since this interaction
may involve
exchanging data
that will ultimately
be consumed by human users.
Availability and
performance will, again,
be our key measures
of reliability.
The final kind of service may
be a data processing pipeline.
Here, we'll care about
things like the throughput
of the system, its ability
to process data correctly,
and the time that it takes
data elements to traverse
the entire pipeline as
measures of reliability.
These three types of
services can end up
having pretty
complex architectures
and infrastructures.
But they all share the same
key feature, reliability.
If that's true, then we
should treat reliability
like other features
of our service.
We'll need to plan and design
for it, architect for it,
and measure it.
But how do we measure the
reliability of our service?
One way to measure
reliability would
be to use uptime, or
the percentage of time
when our service is up.
However, "up" is hard
to define and measure,
and for complex distributed
systems with many failure
modes, this is not very useful.
Instead, we can use an event
or interaction-based model.
We can count the number
of times our users attempt
to interact with our service
over a given time window
and divide the number
of successful attempts
by that total to
get a percentage.
But how do we define what
counts as an interaction,
and what makes for a good
or successful interaction?
That's going to depend
on the kind of service
we're running and managing.
For example, a
website or mobile app
can use HTTP requests,
separated by status code,
as an interaction.
The thing we'll actually
be counting and measuring
is called the Service
Level Indicator, or SLI.
Next, we need a definition
for "good" or "successful."
That will depend on what our
users expect from our service.
In this example, we're defining
success for the profile page
as receiving an HTTP
200 response code.
Now that we've defined
what success looks like,
we need to define
what we'll include
in the total or valid
set of requests.
For example, we may want to
exclude 400s from our count,
because those are likely caused
by misconfigured clients,
and we don't want our
reliability measure
to be penalized as a result. And
now, our availability, as slide
definition, is complete.
Here are other
potential SLI types
you can consider using
for your service.
The SLI menu helps you choose
an SLI for your service
based on who your
users are, what
they expect from your
service, and how they use it.
OK, we know what we're
going to use to measure
the reliability of our service.
Next, we're going to
set a reliability target
for our service.
The target we set is called
the SLO, or Service Level
Objective.
It's a combination of our SLI, a
threshold, and a window of time
over which it's evaluated.
The key thing we're after
is a target or threshold
above which users are happy
and below which they're not.
It might be tempting to
set our target at 100%,
but that would be impossible
to meet, and result
in not being able to make
any changes to our service
and production.
We have a simple rule
of thumb for where
SLO targets should be.
A typical user of
the service should
be just about happy
with the service
when it operates
at those targets.
If the service was
any less reliable,
you'd no longer be meeting
their expectations,
and they would start
to become unhappy.
We call this the happiness test.
When we talk about
the happiness test,
we say "barely
met," because there
are downsides to exceeding
your reliability target, too.
Once your users are happy
with the reliability
of your service, additional
reliability has little value.
Maybe your users
would be happier
if you built new features or
made other service improvements
with the resources that you're
dedicating to far exceeding
your reliability targets.
We've defined reliability as
a key feature of our service
and agreed to use SLIs to
measure reliability and SLOs
to set reliability targets.
But how can we actually
do those things?
Let's have a look at how to
use SLO monitoring and Cloud
Operations to do just that.
Start from the project
dashboard in the Cloud Console.
Go to the Monitoring
menu and select Services.
This will bring you to the list
of services in your Workspace.
As you can see, in
this example, there's
a long list of services.
Services may be
created automatically
from App Engine services, GA
entities, the Istio service
mesh, or Anthos services.
You can also define your
own custom services.
Let's start by figuring
out which of our services
are having issues right now.
To do that, sort the list by the
SLOs with firing alert column.
You can see that the default
service here is at the top.
Let's have a closer look at it.
We've defined three
SLOs for this service.
There's a calendar
month response latency
SLO, which is currently healthy,
with plenty of error budget
still remaining.
There's a rolling
window availability
SLO, which is also healthy.
Finally, we have a
calendar week latency SLO.
There's plenty of
error budget left,
but it's currently
showing as unhealthy.
Let's dig in to see
what's going on.
First, we can see how our SLI
is behaving against our target.
In this example, we're
seeing regular periods
where we're having trouble
meeting that target.
The Error budget tab
shows us our error budget
burn over the selected interval.
This rapid rise
is a great example
of why using calendar-based
rather than rolling SLOs
carries risk.
We recover all of
our error budget
at once when the calendar
period rolls over,
rather than by actually
increasing reliability.
To further investigate
our service,
we give you a variety of
performance and health metrics
that are automatically
gathered for it.
Because this service was defined
based on a GKE namespace,
we have access to
Container, Pod, and Node
metrics for that namespace.
As an example, we can switch
to the Container Restarts
and Uptime view to see
how stable our service is.
We can see that a
number of our containers
restarted right
around the same time.
Further down, we
can see logs being
emitted by our service and
the Kubernetes entity details
below that.
This is how SLO monitoring
in Cloud Operations
brings together
all the information
you need to measure the
reliability of your services,
using SLOs and the diagnostic
and troubleshooting information
that you might need to identify,
triage, and mitigate issues.
Thanks for joining me today.
In this first episode, we
covered some common types
of services, the importance
of treating their reliability
as a key feature, and how to
use an interaction-based model
to measure reliability.
Next, we learned about using
service-level objectives
to set reliability targets.
Finally, we looked at how to
use SLO monitoring in the Cloud
Operations Suite to measure the
reliability of your services
using SLOs.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]